this video was made possible by news
voice a democratized news app created to
fight back against the filter bubbles
caused by corporate media download for
free from news voice calm slash Pakman
or click the link under this video you
know there's something there is
something special about Donald Trump and
this next clip that I'm going to play
demonstrates and I'm obviously saying
special tongue-in-cheek but take a look
at this clip where cecilia Vega began to
ask Donald Trump a question and he
insulted her and in the very trumpian
fashion she's shocked that a picture
look like in a state of shock that's
okay I know you're not thinking you
never do that's right no go ahead go
ahead in a tweet this weekend mister
president you said that it's incorrect
to say you're limiting the scope of the
FBI investigation what does that have to
do with straight well I don't mind
answer the question but you know I'd
like to do the trick has to do with the
other headline in the news which is the
can oh but I know but how about talking
about trade and then we'll get to that
ohh-kay here I'm sorry for laughing I'm
sorry for laughing but Donald Trump is
such I can't say it on David's Pat L own
Davis program because I know we go over
the radio airwaves but Donald Trump is
an extreme a-hole he is a jerk to the
point of absurdity I mean it's it's the
moment is it's a horrible moment for
America to be sure it is disgraceful for
the President of the United States to
behave in this manner right to insult
this woman for no reason whatsoever none
whatsoever it does show I really do have
to list all the things wrong with this
before I go into what I was going to say
but it really shows his his disdain for
women it shows he has absolutely no
respect for women which is the same
thing but I just have to reiterate it
really shows that Donald Trump views
women through the lens of condescension
and this is reflected through here
life particularly with the accusations
against him I mean it makes total sense
that he would want somebody like Brett
Kavanaugh on the Supreme Court because
that is the same type of personality
that he has and so this is a really
disgusting moment for the President of
the United States for this country but
also in nestled in that is the fact that
Donald Trump is a coward mind you I
still have something else to say about
this at the end but I have to point this
out as well
Donald Trump is a coward did you see the
fierceness in Sicilia Vegas voice tone
demeanor and in her eyes when she said
excuse me I was like it's about to go
down like if you've ever been
if you've ever stepped over the line
with a woman in general because what
I've learned about women which is
absolutely amazing and great is that
they really are not going to bite their
tongue and whereas men you know most of
time we back down just like Donald Trump
back down look at how he back down I
mean he says this insulting
condescending statement to this woman
and as soon as she checked them she
didn't even have to get him even get
into it all she had to say was excuse me
and he backed down like the coward that
he is I mean this is like this is the
quintessential example of a chauvinist
of a of a bully earth air of a
chauvinist pig who tries to insult a
woman quickly realizing that he's not up
to he cannot go toe-to-toe with this
individual so I'm a shout out to cecilia
Vega for like I mean that's that was a
read she read him for filth I'm sorry
that's a African American colloquial
that basically means that she she she
told them off without even having to
really try and it was a beautiful moment
for her in terms of her showing Donald
Trump showing the world that Donald
Trump is a bunch of loud he's not even a
bark right you know all all bark and no
bite he's just a loud mouth foul-mouthed
individual with no respect for anyone
else but at the core of
he's a coward now what I wanted to say
at the beginning but I had to really
outline all the things that was wrong
with this is that Donald Trump is such
he's a clown he's a jerk he's a joke and
you know what for people who who like
jerks and in your own head I want you to
substitute jerk for another word because
we're on radio but but for people who
like that they probably think that this
was the funniest thing that they ever
saw yesterday and they are applauding
him now part of me I am a jerk I'm
personally I you know I too suffer from
a Hillary and so I laughed at this
segment and then I had a pause and come
you know and think about it and see
everything that was wrong with it
so thankfully I have the ability to
transcend my Jirka tude I'm an idiot and
amongst other things but the point is
this is that there's an entire group of
people out there who will see this as a
pro they they will see this as something
redeeming in Donald Trump they love this
about Donald Trump and isn't that just
isn't that so indicative of the times in
which we live where we can see something
and we can whether we initially see how
repugnant it is or like me it takes a
moment for you to compose yourself and
really and analyze it from a decent
human being perspective either/or
you know I gotta include myself in a
good group obviously but there's an
entire group of us who can see this and
see the problem with it whereas you have
in another segment of a society who see
of American of the voting electorate
more specifically who look at this and
they see nothing wrong in fact they see
this is the exact reason why they voted
for Donald Trump and they applaud him
and they want more of this this this is
the dichotomy of America this is where
we've broken down into and that is a
problem that's brewing underneath the
surface of America that we're now
getting to a fever pitch and we really
have to see where these two factions
actually go